your favorite memory of your dad that
wanted you to get up on stage this
wasn't in the plan I worked TV
production for the last seven years of
my life at the end of last year I was
working a show and I was just getting sh
from everybody for no reason and I was
like yo I'm fing tired of this and we
started really getting traction and do a
lot of on the internet I was like you
know what it we're going to put all my
eggs in one basket and we're going to
come see what the I can do and here we
are now so I I'll tell you something man
I've heard people online be like
noism who who else would I rather tour
with who else would I rather hang out
with it makes no sense to me why I'm
just going to hang with some dude I
never met now if look if you have kids
you know I think you spend something
crazy like 19 and a half years total
with your kids and 18 of them are the
first 18 of their life okay so to have
bonus time with him this is truly the
best time of my career I've done a ton
of show it's never been better than this